Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling in Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today's episode is with
somebody who I've actually
really enjoyed getting to know
better and chatting it various
conferences that we've attended
together and some mini symposia
that we've done, which is
Johannes brand set up.
So he's got an interesting
profile because not only is he a
professor at England's at EU
Johannes Kepler University in
Austria, but he also founded or
Co founded a startup recently
called MEAI.
His background is one that is
very well positioned to help
advance the state of machine
learning for, for for CFD and I
guess CAE more broadly.
And yes, this is an episode on
machine learning again, I had
sometimes feel bad that I keep
doing this, but I think this
season there's a mixture of of
episodes and I still feel that
there is value in going through
the machine learning topic.
And it's selfishly something
that I I'm constantly interested
in learning more about and
learning more about.
It is one thing that I always do
when I speak to Yanis.
And he has an interesting
background because whilst he has
AI guess a high energy physics
background that he he, he did
and he was at CERN and he worked
in that sort of area.
He then moved into the machine
learning side, I guess, having
spent time with Max Welling at
the Amsterdam University in the
machine learning lab.
And then I think he also, well,
I don't think I know that he was
then at Microsoft Research where
Max was also out.
And so the two of them
collaborated a lot.
You know, if you don't know who
Max Welling is, well, first
Google, his name is one of The
Pioneers of machine learning.
But I also did an episode with
him in the last season that I
think was really interesting and
I think he must have been
inspired by Max a little bit,
even though we didn't talk about
it in this episode, because Max
also has been a serial start up
founder.
And the reason I said that he
has an interesting background is
because whilst he was at
Microsoft, he also worked on the
Aurora machine learning for web
and climate project.
That I think is extremely useful
when you have people who have
gone through these major
projects in another field
because they bring with them
lessons and learnings that are
important.
And, and what Johannes has been
doing is first of all, bringing
a very academic mindset to this
academic in the terms of
publishing and transparency,
which I think is very welcome.
So you'll find in the link in
the YouTube a couple of the
papers that he's published and
and his startup has published a
new sort of transformer based
model that I, at least from my
reading, is unique and certainly
seems to be at the one of the
most cutting edge in
state-of-the-art models out
there today, both in terms of
conceptual but also the accuracy
on the data sets that they've
shown.
But I admire his vision and his
willingness to try and solve the
problem rather than being
focused on the model, as in some
people seem to, once they come
up with a model, fixate on that
being it, rather than being
willing to consider that their
model may be the right thing at
the time, but then there'll be
other models that get better.
And he, his willingness to
accept that, I think is a breath
of fresh air and definitely will
help the community to, to
involve, to evolve.
So that's what we talked about
today.
Really we, we tried to go
through and discuss, you know,
more the general topics around
machine learning, but really
diving into this transformer
based approach that he has.
And I'm trying to understand
some of his thoughts around the
similarities to null operators,
some of the slight differences,
some of the links to I guess
graph neural Nets and mesh graph
Nets that probably most people
are aware of.
And then we talked a little bit
about the process of forming the
startup and some discussions
around future topics.
As with anything, I always feel
bad because I finished the
episode and I think I really
should have discussed more or,
or, or dived into certain
topics, but I'm conscious it was
already over, you know, an hour
20 and people will, you know,
fall asleep listening to some of
these episodes.
But hopefully it's enough to
spark your interest and
encourage you to read more about
the topics that we discussed.
And please leave any comments or
let me know if you have any
suggestions for for other
topics.
But for now, please sit back and
enjoy what I found an extremely
interesting episode with
Johannes Bransetta.
Cool.
All right, thanks for joining me
today.
I wanted to have a chat with you
for a while.
We've had some nice discussions
over wine and and coffee, but
nothing public.
So this is the public version of
our discussions, but maybe it'd
be good for people to learn a
little bit more about you.
You know, where you're at today.
Yeah.
Who?
Who is Johannes?
Yeah, thanks first of all.
Thanks really Neil for for
having me.
It's it's a great pleasure
finally seeing this guitars here
in a one to one setting, so to
say.
Yeah, my background is actually
I'm I'm a learned physicist,
some say a failed physicist.
But after my PHDI switched to
machine learning, as many people
also did.
I have spent time with
Sepulchreiter and three years in
Amsterdam with Maxwelling.
I was in industry for two years
at Microsoft Research.
And there at Microsoft Research
I really, really discovered my
likings for large scale
simulation, especially for
weather and climate modelling,
because these are like some of
the biggest problems you can
have and you can tackle with
machine learning.
I also saw the transformative
impact on this, on the systems,
and that was then the point
where I decided to to do my own
thing to, but to apply it not to
known problems like weather, but
rather uncharted territories
like engineering, simulation and
this kind of thing.
And I decided to get my own
group at university to build up
my knowledge base back in
Austria, where I'm coming from.
And along the road.
It also happened that I founded
a start up MEII where we do this
simulations at scale and where
things are coming together with
a bit more compute and a bit
more resources.
Nice.
Well, we'll we need to dive into
each of those, but maybe the
first one was the Aurora
project.
I guess this is maybe it, it was
subtaneously both a motivation,
I think certainly for me and
others who saw what was
happening in weather and climate
and was saying, you know, surely
we could do that in engineering.
But also it was an example of a,
yeah, a real large scale
project.
So what was it like working on
that Aurora?
What was the key lessons you
learned both from maybe an ML
point of view, but also a
project and a team point of
view?
So the actual Aurora team was
pretty small.
I mean, all the credits to to
Chris Bodner versus Pransma,
Megan Stanley and a Lucic who
did that, all the heavy lifting
afterwards to finalize this
project, to train to build the
data loader.
The Aurora was the learnings I
think are threefold.
First of all, with computer
vision tricks, you can get very,
very far in engineering or
scientific application.
In the end it was a swing
transformer trained in in a 3D
swing transformer.
Secondly that the the data
engineering is potentially the
hardest one and and thirdly that
weather has a very unfair
advantage for machine learning
because nobody knows how weather
is functioning.
So you, you will always train a
machine learning model on like
actual data, which basically has
the actual physical laws hidden.
Whereas the, the the numerical
methods, they have to come up
with these laws by themselves.
And that already brings these,
these key interests of mine,
which is that that neural
surrogates will never replace
numerics.
They will just be a different
branch which depending on how
you play the card acts in your
favour.
And that it's all about
engineering and scaling these,
these things to this, to this
basically to this problems where
they really have an impact and
there really matters.
And the impact for Aurora, you
could see if you look through
this, this small, through this
downstream tasks that the larger
these challenges are, the more
impact you can basically
generate.
Yeah, it seemed to definitely
spur on.
And now it seems that there's
been so many of the weather and
climate models, it's almost got
not congested, but there's
there's, there's quite a few
coming out.
And so it's not obviously so
clear how each are progressing
past each other and and how much
are those of just an individual
groups need to have their own
model, if you know what I mean.
But did you, I guess one of the
big things that I want to
discuss today with you in
particular was to dive into, I
guess where machine learning,
how can I phrase this machine
learning for engineering, for
CFD, for CAE.
You know, it's something I've
spoken to a few people about and
there's a lot going on, but it's
hasn't always been so clear
where the big breakthroughs will
be or how, how good are we today
and where we're going.
It it's it's still seems a
congested space with different
opinions, you know, with pins on
one side and then these sort of
mesh graph Nets and other
things.
So it's a bit of a, an
open-ended question to you, but
I guess like where do you see
the state-of-the-art?
What what's been your journey
from the sort of mesh graph Nets
towards your current thinking?
Like how, how have you try to
solve this problem, I guess.
And let's, let's say, let's take
CFD, maybe is the the the
problem like automotive
aerodynamics for example?
Yeah, that's a very good, my
favorite topic actually making
the connections to weather.
Let's let's say what what
basically was driving this
weather modelling.
I would say that NVIDIA was the
first with the forecast net
paper to to bring out a model
which worked that was trained on
error 5, which is a publicly
available large scale data set.
Depending on how you sample you
get roughly a petabyte of data
or a few 100 terabytes of data
from it.
And then you do basically mean
squared error training that that
was the the scene set and and as
soon as this problem was defined
of this input output relation of
this metrics of of what to test,
then people did what, what they
do best.
They optimize on this sort of
problems.
If you go to engineering, things
are very different in, in many,
many aspects.
So first of all, we don't have
this data set.
We don't have an error five data
set.
And even if you had an error
five data set, I mean, there are
now at least 2-3 publicly
available CFD data sets.
Needless to say that my favorite
one is the Tri ML data set which
are industrial standard.
But even if these data sets are
out there, people don't know how
to train on them.
And everyone trains differently.
And this comes from the fact
that we just don't know what you
really want to optimize.
There is people who sub sample
parts of the surface and map to,
to pressure values on the
surface, people who sub sample
part of surface and volume and
so on and so forth.
So similarly to whether we have
to figure out what's the right
task, what's the right learning
task, which we which we have to
to do or like the tasks in, in
order to really develop the
right models in the right
frameworks for that.
Secondly, I think what is also
very different to weather is
that we have this input output
relation.
So in weather, it's always clear
you take time T and you map to T
+ 1.
That's basically a segmentation
task on steroids because in the
end every pixel on the Earth
gets mapped to but with pixel on
the earth like a time time point
later, which you can basically
you can take all the models from
computer vision.
And obviously there is some
tricks with resolution and and
if you take the sphere into
account, yes or not.
But in the end it's it's a pixel
segmentation task.
And this is definitely not true
for for many CFD related tasks
because the task there is from a
pure numerical perspective, you
have a geometry which you can
characterize with couple of
parameters, probably less than
100 even.
And then you get this
full-fledged flow fields around
and on the car so that the
actual input to output ratio is
very, very different.
And we don't have architectures,
we don't have frameworks, we
don't have an understanding of
how to tackle that.
But that makes it so exciting I
would say.
And maybe thirdly, if you, if
you really look at these weather
models and what they can do with
hurricane predictions and so on,
obviously there's always room
for improvement and obviously
you can go farther and farther.
But if you just look what
happened in the last two years
and the resources and weather
are I would say it's tiny, tiny
fractions to the resources in
LLM and and video generation.
You see this tremendous progress
and what what hard problems and
hard multi scale problems we are
already able to model and which
we can able better than
numerics.
So it's very clear that if done
rightly and if the right
incentives are there, this
progress and this type of
complexity we're able to do in
in CFD.
Obviously then we have to play
the game numerics and ML
together.
Yeah, which is then I think the
hardest task to answer.
Yeah, that, that does seem, I
guess the joke that the Earth is
always the Earth.
And so the geometry is sort of,
you know, not so much the
problem.
And yeah, I guess it all depends
on what is the data.
You're right, in the CFD
example, the geometries could be
hugely varying and that link
between the geometry and the
volume is a Yeah, it it's so the
geometry is geometry and the
boundary conditions is
ultimately what affects the
flows.
So where have you seen, I guess
a lot of people listening to
this and myself included,
probably had their first
introduction with, you know,
what the Deep Mind team did with
with mesh graph Nets.
I mean, there was obviously
stuff before that, but that felt
like the bit when everyone stood
up and and noticed why?
Why do you not feel that that is
the right approach?
It's always right or wrong.
It's always hard to to to judge.
But I think that the, the mesh
craft net and, and, and and and
graph neural network simulators
from the Peter Battaglia group
were tremendously important
milestone in this field, mostly
because they, they were writing
down this learning problem.
And I myself went into this
field of simulations because of
these papers trying to model
particle particle systems.
What, what we noticed back in
the days, I mean, this is like
5-6 years ago, that it's
tremendously hard to model all
particle particle interaction as
numerics is doing.
So if you have this 10,000
system of particles and they
interact and you have you have
something like a graph neural
network and you have to make all
these interactions correctly
because otherwise the temporal
integration will will just,
yeah, just go, go, go crazy.
That's just a very hard learning
problem.
And this is not what machine
learning is really good at.
Machine learning is good at to
understand the global dynamics,
to understand the behavior of
the system, to understand where
things are going on a global
scale, but not on a particle
particle scale.
So I, I think from, from, from
setting up this learning
problem, this was a tremendously
important step.
Obviously new ways of, of, of of
models are coming the way for me
personally, it was a big
breakthrough that we started to,
to see things as fields.
So everything in my, in my head
is a field.
And because you a field is
something which evolves over
time.
It can be an occupancy field,
which tells you where is mass,
where is no mass.
It can be assigned distance
field.
It can be a velocity field, it
can be a displacement field,
whatever field you want.
But it's much easier for a, for
a model to, to tackle, which is
actually obviously the, the next
step if you think of this whole
scientific machine learning and
no operator and, and, and so on
and so forth.
And in the end, I mean, this is
also how you, you model the,
the, the weather.
So I, I think conceptually from
me personally, from me, I don't
know how it is for others.
Understanding that you can model
large scale systems as a field
was, was breaking a lot of
boundaries in, in terms of
scalability.
Because if you model a system of
10 million, 100 million
particles as a field, it's
computation and not the problem.
It's from a learning
perspective, it's not the
problem because you just don't
need all these particles.
You you'll learn the dynamics
with the very heavily subsampled
representation and and and and
obtaining the full field is also
not a problem because this this
exists.
So I would say for me
understanding what machine
learning is really good at and
and and and and and what
numerics is really good at and
and and and and playing those
two on, on on those two fronts
was was was making the the
difference.
Yeah.
Well, one thing that I've maybe
would appreciate you explaining
to the audience and maybe let's
first introduce some of the work
that you've done in this recent
paper of yours.
So you you developed this
transformer based approach, what
you call it anchor based
universal physics.
Trump What?
What?
Well, maybe you explain what?
Yeah, we.
Have actually a couple of works
of 1 is which we call Universal
Physics transformer.
That's basically how we do
latent space modelling of
logical system.
Then we did something which is
called Neural DM where we
applied those to to multi flows
and and and multi.
Particle systems and then we,
we, we recently applied this to
to large scale CFD similar
framework, similar approach,
which we call anchored branched
because these are the two
ingredients which which which we
need to do in order to get this
to work on large systems.
So in that context, what I'm
hoping you could do is maybe
explain a little bit, because
there's a lot of people who
listen to this podcast who are
maybe not ML specialists, but
are CFD primarily specialists
who are now, you know, more and
more interested in ML and maybe
actually developing it and, and
yeah, sort of progressing.
And you mentioned a really
interesting point to me and I'm
hoping you can explain this in a
way that is understandable by
others is that I, and I guess
some of this is a maths
exercise, but you know, and I've
been guilty of this.
Sometimes there's this
hierarchical thought process of
being like, OK, you've got some
sort of graph based thing where
it's more like point to point.
Then you've got a new operator
where it's like more to
solutions or fields.
And then I initially thought of,
OK, and then you have
Transformers.
And yet you see some people who
say, well, everything is a new
operator if you do the maths or
design it.
So can you explain and maybe
dive a little bit deeper into
that concept of solution mapping
or field mapping and then how it
lakes transforms?
Because I think it is a little
bit confusing for for for
people.
So if yeah, if we could maybe
get into that, that would be in
in the context of let's say this
drive air, ML or car, however
you want to explain it.
Yeah, happily to do so.
So for me, in fact neural
operate and this is also how it
is introduced is something which
maps between function spaces,
which is very yeah, which is not
very informative if you if you,
because what does it mean?
You map between function spaces.
But I always think of it as you
have two functions, one input
function, 1 output function.
And no matter what you sample
from the input function and what
you predict on the output
function, this has to be
fulfilled.
Meaning that if a sample 10
points from the input function,
I should be able to predict as
many points as I want from the
output function and those points
I predict are actually on the
output function.
If a sample with the same
network with the same operator 6
points from the input function,
I should also get the same 10
points and if I want more
points, I get more points on the
output function.
Obviously there is a limit.
If a sample to little input
points, then obviously the
approximation network is not
able to really get the
information needs.
But if if this this this
sampling limit is is reached no
matter how many points and where
those points are spaced, it
should always give you some sort
of representation which allow
you to construct the output
function.
So in the latent space this
mapping is, then is then, so to
say, resolution agnostic and and
that with some small tricks you
can do with convolutions, with
full node operators, with
Transformers and so on and so
forth.
And obviously Transformers with
their.
Can I if I've seen to it just
for one second, just to make it
even more clearer, when you say
sampling the input function and
the output function by input
function, you're meaning like
the geometry surface in this
conceptual sense and the output
function being let's say the
volume.
Would that be 1 interpretation?
Yes, for example you can.
You can think of it that the
input is, the is the geometry
and the output is either the
field on the geometry or the
field in the volume, or both
actually.
And the idea of this so where
you know, this sounds like a bit
of AI.
Remember when this first came
out, I was I think it was billed
as a resolution independent.
So it which always to ACFD
person feels like the no free
lunch sort of theorem.
Like how can this possibly Yeah,
you know, how can that be true?
You're basically saying I don't
need to map the entire geometry,
I can just take a few and still
get the same answers.
So where's the catch?
I I guess on this?
Yeah.
I mean that that's a very good
point.
And I think I can make my, my
point very clear with, with
really now going to CFD and,
and, and before that, I really
have to say, if people think of
resolution, we always think
again of this segmentation as,
as we do with weather, right?
You have a certain number of
longitude and latitude points.
And if we double those points,
do we get higher resolution or
do we just have an interpolation
and so on and so forth.
So can we just run our whatever
unit and interpolate between
this resolution or is there a
way to get this stuff resolved?
So there's always this input
output mapping and obviously it
will end up with interpolation
effect.
So either you interpolate
somewhere in your network or you
interpolate on the output grid
because as you said, no free
lunch.
But if we go to CFD, things are
a bit different, especially that
the input output resolution, as
I said before, is very different
or input output connection.
And, and actually we show in
this recent paper that if you
subsample a few of the points,
so both on geometry and surface
and, and you do some, some
training, there is a certain
amount of points, but the
performance stagnates.
So if it's, it's for for tribe
ML, this is roughly 128 Ki think
or 256 I, I, I don't know by
heart.
And if you then add more points,
the performance is not getting
better because all the, the
information which in neural
network needs is in those
points.
And, and if you sample it, let's
say cleverly so, so that the
distribution really covers the
whole surface and the critical
parts.
And then also points at the
closer to the surface and the
volume are represented
correctly.
All this, this type of stuff.
But there is a certain amount of
points where you really capture
the whole phenomenon.
And that's the, the, the, the
resolution invariant.
So to say.
Obviously, if you go lower with
the point to sample, you lose a
bit of representation.
So you don't, you don't resolve
the full physics.
So you're never able to really
recover the whole physics.
But there is a, a certain amount
of points you need.
And this is for, for each type
of physics problem that you have
the full information in the
network.
And then obviously depends how
good your network is.
And then obviously it makes much
more sense to not have a network
which again spits out this 128
points, but which conceptually
is able to spit out as many
points as you want because
that's the new operator, right?
That you can really get every
point on the output function if
if needed.
And this is something which is
which is very, very interesting
in CFD.
Yeah.
So I guess, again, correct me if
I'm wrong, if I'm distilling
this correctly, is you're saying
if the surface in reality has
8,000,000 points or whatever the
exact number is, you're saying
that you should be able by
training and sampling
progressively different points,
you shouldn't need more than
256,000 to actually do as good
job as 8 million.
Whereas I guess we've the
analogy.
I suppose what I'm trying to
pick out is with mesh graph Nets
or with graph neural Nets,
people could in theory take a
million, but they would normally
like down sample, but they're
down sampling at least.
Correct me if I'm wrong, you are
then changing the problem
statement in this it it will
give you a different answer and
and that I know was certain
experience that we had and
others have had where you go
well, how much do I downsample
and where do I pick the point to
downsample?
And so a lot of people take an
8,000,000 cell can't fit in AGP
memory and take 500,000 but
they're worried when they do
inference they then would have
to give the exact same mesh
distribution or if they give a
different mesh distribute.
Do do you know what I'm getting?
At that's lovely.
I mean you, you say the most
important point, which I forgot.
Obviously if you have to
calculate something with drag or
lift coefficient for which you
you really need to get the
correct value.
You need the full simulation
mesh, the full 8 to 9 million
surface mesh.
And obviously the network has to
give you this full mesh because
otherwise you're never able to
calculate correct drag and lift
coefficient.
But the network is giving you
this full network idea.
Sorry, this full drag and lift
coefficient on the full surface
mesh, no matter if you give it
64,128 thousand 256,000 input
points, it's just at some in
number of input points the
output is stagnating or the
performance is stagnating
because you have reached the
maximum performance and the the
input and and obviously you can
also give 8 million input
points.
The the the self attention will
be terribly slow and I don't
know what what parallelization
tricks you need to do, but
nevertheless it will give you
the same answer in the output.
So you can trustically reduce
what you give as input as long
as the output still gives you
the correct answer.
And that's, that's the magic we
we got from transformer, which
we cannot do with with other
methods for.
So for other methods we really
had to make the problem much
easier, which is obviously
giving you the wrong physics.
So if we down move on to and I
guess this is the the novelty
that I saw in your approach and
and I thought it was good to
double click on a bit.
It's why the Transformer, what
specifically is that
architecture giving you versus
alternatives because yeah, and
how and how that relate, if you
could maybe go into a little bit
because Transformers, I think
most people know conceptually,
you know, tokens, etcetera,
LLMS, but maybe not in the
context of CFD.
Yeah, so transformer are
tremendously flexible,
tremendously optimised and and
and tremendously well understood
powerhouse power work, power
horse in, in, in deep learning,
right.
They are they the the engine
behind large language model
computer vision and and all
these tricks are already done
and they have a few certain
properties which are super nice.
The 1st is the the invariance
with respect to sequence length.
So no matter how long the the
sequence length is which
corresponds how many points you
input to the network, it will do
the same calculations, right?
Which is very important for the
scaling properties.
And then they have this how to
say so I call it discretization
conversion.
So if you sample more points in
a in an error in an area, it is
basically it will converge to
some to some field.
So, so the more points to
sample, the, the better the
resolution gets, which is
obviously extremely valid,
important property for this new
operator paradigm.
They they are made.
So the transformer paradigm is
made and, and stress tested
again and again and again for
scaling, meaning that you can
build larger models, that you
can ingest larger data sets.
Yeah.
And, and, and all these things
make them an ideal fit for us.
I mean, I'm very happy that not
everyone is using Transformers.
That gives us some edge, but
yeah.
But specifically, So how do you
tokenize the problem then?
How could people conceptually
understand, you know, mesh graph
Nets conceptually was I have a
node which corresponds to my
mesh, I have some edges and then
I take that like you're not
taking a token per node clearly
or that wouldn't scale, right.
So how could people conceptually
think of that sort of tokenizing
the the surface or the volume?
I think that the way you have to
approach this is not from a
physicist perspective, but from
a computer vision perspective.
So what do people do in computer
vision?
So I think when do, when you do
something like image generation
where you type in a prompt, I
want a horse in the, in the in
the woods with whatever.
So you have some text and then
you mix that with some image
which is generated, right?
So you have basically 2 streams
and, and the second important
part is this concept of
patching.
So the transformer for for text,
it's very clear each word gets a
token.
So each word in a sentence or
probably each each sign or
whatever is tokenized for for
images, small patches of the
image will correspond to a token
and a word.
So everything is a token which
then can interact with each
other.
But in in language, it's the
token's words in, in envision,
the tokens is small patches of
of an image.
So if we do the same thing in in
CFD, what we actually have, we
have basically three type of of
information.
We have the information of the
geometry.
So in general, what geometry we
have, we have the information of
the volume and we have the
information of basically the
physics on the on the geometry.
So it makes sense to treat this
as either two or three
modalities as we call it, right?
So as as you have text and and
and image and then you can
tokenize either small areas,
which makes sense.
If you if you look, try to
encode the geometry so small
neighboring areas get pulled
into one token so that you have
this information which gets
locally aggregated.
Or you can for, for actually
doing physics, you just take
some samples of the mesh and see
them as a token.
And then you have the same
setup, you have different
tokens, they represent different
physic objects or physic parts
of the physics.
And then similar to what people
do in computer vision, you let
those tokens speak to each
other.
You like, like this volume
tokens between each other and
the volume tokens to the surface
and so on and so forth.
So it's really borrowing a lot
of concepts from computer vision
because that's what it works.
So if I understand it correctly,
essentially what you're doing is
patching.
So if you were to look at the
surface mesh and if you have,
you know, visually, if you
looked at it and you had a clump
of 5 by 5, then you, you would
have, you know, 25 cells and
however many edges and nodes,
you would say, OK, well, that
can just become one token and
then you go into the next, the
next.
So if you, so essentially you're
able to go from 8,000,000 points
and instead of taking 8 million
tokens, you would have you know,
10,000 or what whatever the
number is, is that.
And the assumption is that the
differences within that patch
should be small enough to be not
important.
If you were to take too big a
patch, I assume you would lose
some accuracy because you're
losing some local information.
Would that be fair to say there
comes a cut off point?
Yeah.
So if you if you talk about
representing the geometry, what
you correctly said, you can do
two things, right.
You can treat each point of the
geometry individually.
It turns out this, this drive ML
data set and so on so forth.
The information is so rich.
So in order to really represent
the geometry, you need roughly,
I don't know, half a million
points.
So it makes sense to pool them
before, to aggregate them
locally, and then to use those
as, as, as tokens.
That's just computationally much
more efficient to have some sort
of pooling that the number of
tokens is not exploding.
You could also obviously use
representatives of the geometry
as your points, but it makes
sense to pull them before.
And the same in the volume,
right?
You're essentially, instead of
taking 130 million nodes, you're
breaking them into patches which
themselves take into.
Yeah, the The funny thing is so
so there is this tool.
So we always have the the number
of points which it takes to
represent physics correctly.
This is 2 slightly different
things.
So for the geometry we really
need a lot of tokens in order to
really capture the geometry
because the geometry is
influencing the physics and so
on and so forth.
For the volume we don't need so
many points.
So we we only need roughly
128,000 or or even less to
really capture the physics.
So that's we are totally fine to
pick those points individually
and actually performance is not
degrading much if we go to 32 or
64,000 that will get more
interesting if we get even
larger data sets.
But then you can also use some
tricks.
So there it's obviously fully
fine to use individual points.
So in that context, is it fair?
A mental model is that you're
saying that the number of points
that are needed for a numerical
solver should not be a one to
one mapping.
That you shouldn't think just
because I need half a billion
points to solve my PDE, that I
should.
I should need half a billion
points for my mission, my
machine learning model to learn
the behaviour that we need to
break from this concept of
almost one to one mapping.
It's that part of your argument,
because that's not most people
that I think assumed in the GNN
that I need to have this sort of
1 to one mapping that I'm, I'm
sort of taking my notes and I'm
putting that into my ML and
that's the most logical way of
learning the problem.
Yeah.
So I, I really like those
questions, I have to say.
So I would my argument is, and I
mean you tell me you're the CFT
expert, but I would say what a
model has to be able to do is it
has to produce the simulation
mesh.
So it has to give you
predictions on the simulation
mesh both on the on the surface
and in the volume.
And this is not only cars, it
should be hold for airplanes and
so on and so forth.
And if we, if we think of meshes
which approach a billion of mesh
points and where this is #1
condition, we cannot, we cannot
use paralisation here because
then we end up using thousand
GPU's and this is not scaling
very well.
I'm looking at the actual
information content.
So it has to be the model has to
be able to produce this this
rich outputs in order to be a
good tool to use.
But on the other hand you don't
need this huge output for
training.
You can train on much much
smaller sub sampled version of
the same problem.
However, you have to make sure
with null operator learning with
function approximation that
those models you trained are
then in inference or in test
time.
Able to give you the full answer
on the full simulation measure.
I think this is the true CFD
problem or the true learning
problem similar to the error 5
setup in Feather modelling which
we have to do in CFD.
So you yeah, so this is an
interesting point that I it's
good to maybe briefly discuss
which is at imprint time.
So we discussed about training
time, you know what you take,
how many of the points, how many
do you agglomerate, you know,
etcetera, etcetera.
But I guess what you're getting
to now is the inference time,
which is something that maybe is
not so obvious to some people,
but for me was always a bit of a
conceptual challenge, which is
how do you generate the mesh to
do the inference on.
So normally if you are running a
normal CFD problem or you're
taking the driver ML data set,
you split it into a train and
test, but both of them already
have a mesh generated.
You know, we're giving it you.
So you already have the mesh.
But the real life engineering
problem is I want to predict a
new geometry that I've never
seen before.
And the question is, do I have
to mesh it like I would mesh
ACFD problem or can I just take
the CAD or can I just do some
arbitrary case?
Am I understanding it right that
this is sort of your argument of
the neural operator or the field
sort of base approach That if I
take a new geometry of a new car
that I haven't done anything
before on and I mesh it 5
different ways and then ask your
model to give me an A
prediction, it should
essentially give pretty much the
same answer for those five
different ways of meshing it.
Yes, I think this is the true.
To an end, to a point.
I mean, two things.
One, one thing I haven't said
so, so I I was talking about
the, the difference in in
training and inference mesh.
I also should say for for us
it's very important that the
algorithm we are developing
works for for cat geometry.
So if you input interference
only the cat geometry, you're
able to obtain the full surface
and full volume without giving
any information of the surface
and volume mesh in inference.
The only thing the model gets
the CFD input.
Obviously the performance
slightly degrades, but I'm
amazed how well that works.
And you can do that by using,
obviously in training that the
simulation mesh and, and, and
using some tricks on the
simulation mesh that because
obviously you need this
information in some way in
training.
But that you can tell your model
how to work with, with basically
structured points in the in the
volume and, and certain points
on the on the surface such that
interference it's the model is
able to deal without any of
those meshings.
And I think this is somehow the
true power of, of these deep
learning models because they
cannot only scale.
You can, you can think of that
the whole CFD compressed
simulation is suddenly
compressed to, to neural network
weights.
You just have to ask them the,
the, the model, which region in
the, in the 3D you want to have
the prediction.
But you can also do that from
pure COD inputs.
And so, so no storing, no
whatever, right?
And yeah, this is truly
exciting, I would say.
Yeah, I think that's one of the
bits that I think is the true
test.
Because if you have to generate
a mesh, the real time element of
the prediction starts to go.
Because for many people,
generating the mesh, the volume
of the surface is itself quite a
challenge.
And I think most people would
prefer to go straight from a CAD
geometry or, or at least be less
sensitive, you know, to, to, to,
to the mesh.
The, the only conceptual
challenge to this, and I, I
don't know if we've even
discussed this before, but I'll
just throw it out there, which I
think still is part of the
challenge in people's heads is
if you do ACFD simulation, you
would expect there to be a
difference with the mesh, right?
It it should give a difference
if I run that driver ML with a a
grid that's half as course or
twice as fine.
I want it to give a difference
because by having a course of
mesh I have higher numerical
error which should affect the
flow field.
And if I have a much finer mesh
I should see a difference
because I'm reducing the
numerical error.
I think where it gets a little
bit harder with the notion of
sort of resolution independence,
is it sort of breaks from that
mindset that, that I should be
able to give you a mesh that's
twice as fine or twice as
coarse.
And yet I get the same answer.
It it, it sort of messes with
the CFD mind because you think
it should be different because I
I'm expecting in my normal PD
solver for it to be different
but it's not remember.
Oh, it's, yeah.
I mean, actually this was one of
the reasons how we developed
this, this anchor tokens, we
call them anchor tokens approach
because this very much is, I
think the neural analogy of what
you're saying.
So what these anchor tokens are
and basically they are the
reasons how we can scale.
So we train on a selected set of
tokens on the surface and on the
volume.
And those tokens, as we already
said, they need to capture the
physics.
So it's, it needs to be a
certain amount, but they are
sufficiently well to train with
self attention everything on
Transformers and in fear and
cyber.
What we do, we, we, we pick
these tokens.
Those are representative points
in the whole 3D volume from
surface and the volume.
And then basically those tokens
span the weights of the keys and
values.
So in the in the Transformer,
you have three different blocks
and those span two blocks.
So you do a first pass of the
model with those tokens and then
this is fixed.
So you basically have what
you've built is you've built a
model which which is is a
representation of of your full
flow and and then you can ask
for specific points in the
volume or on the surface to get
another value.
And these points can be
arbitrary points, any point.
And this point will just run
through the the model with all
these weights already fixed.
So, so it only like a small part
of the model is adjusted and it
will give you an output.
And obviously the more anchor
points you have, the finer this
this resolution gets, the better
this prediction are obviously
until a certain threshold,
right.
So if you think of 16,000 points
in the volume, you can still
reconstruct the full flow field,
but it's it's not the full
accuracy.
If you go to 32,064 thousand at
some point, if the training
allowed it, you will have the
full field covered.
And then with these, with these
points, you can get arbitrary
find resolution and similar to
in CFD and you and you cover all
the the points in space.
I think I see this anchor points
really as as some, some some
sort of of of this computation
cells in CFD.
Obviously the the discrepancy
between number of mesh cells you
need in CFD to get the
simulation to converge towards
anchor points you need in order
to cover the full mesh.
Is is trusted different?
But it's just because AI is
trusted different, different
than the Mac simulation.
But there is this analogy.
And obviously if you if you
don't use any of these points,
it's very, very hard to
construct these dynamics.
Yeah.
I think conceptually some of the
interesting challenge of that
is, correct me if I'm wrong, but
you, your ground truth is your
train data.
So you feel that if you match
the train data, that's the best
it can be.
Right.
But the training data itself is
dependent on the mesh.
And so one of the, I guess
research topics that people have
discussed is, well, how about
multi fidelity?
So you, you know, you have some
high fidelity data, some low
fidelity data, but how?
I'm so going off a tangent on
this a little bit, But one of
the things I always say to
people is if you have a concept
of like a foundational model
where you're saying, OK, I'm
going to have a model that
predicts cars.
I'm more and unless my mind is
just too static it it's a
foundational model, but just for
the mesh design that you've
picked and the CFD method you've
picked.
If I then go and change that CFD
method and regenerate the driver
ML with like a RANS data set,
I'm going to get a different
answer.
So it's sort of hard to
conceptually imagine the ML
being like a foundation model
because the, the input data
itself is so dependent on the
settings you have of the CFD.
So ideally it should really be
like experimental date should be
the, the, the real ground truth.
But it's, it's sort of a little
bit of a philosophical thing
where, yeah, the ML model is
only as good as the training
data that it has.
And so if now you've sort of
solved the ML problem, well, I'm
not saying you've solved it.
It's almost the data is the most
important bit now.
I couldn't agree more.
So, so I, I, I would say talking
about foundation models for
engineering is very, very
dangerous because you're kind of
data agnostic in a way.
You in the end, what goes into
these models is a huge amount of
knowledge in this data
generation.
And as you said, data on
numerics is not the ground
truth.
It's just one version of, of, of
our reality, right.
And, and machine learning is not
replacing whatever this, this
version of reality, it's giving
a certain new access to this
reality.
So I, I think the power of
machine learning comes when you,
when you really pick certain
areas where it's tremendously
important to have this
surrogates and to have this vast
iteration to have whatever and
then really think what it takes
to build those surrogates.
But I think from a modelling
perspective we are especially in
this static systems, we are
pretty far that we can give them
enough data and high fidelity
data and so on and so forth.
We can build these systems with
reasonable errors compared to
the data is trained on.
The question is then always how
to interact with numeric.
So if depends on what you want,
but I think that the power and
the true transformation comes
when when numerics and CFD
really go and deep networks
really go hand in hand and not
as as two different parties.
Maybe I should also say to that
we were doing this drive ML data
set now for I don't know 10
months like quite intensively
trying different things.
We've reformulated the learning
problem ourselves a couple of
times.
So what we actually want to
train, what we actually want to
test and so on and so forth,
because it's really, really hard
to because it's, it's just not a
replacement of the CFD.
Your model is just doing
something different and you have
to frame that there's a problem.
And and so that's why I think
these two fields need to come
closer together that these
questions are answered.
Yeah, no, I and I was just
looking off to the side because
I was just double checking if I
was correct that the error five
data set is a combination of
actual satellite data, right
observations with some sort of
modelling.
So it is quite different in and
I think that's kind of my point
that the weather stuff has
literally got what the
satellites is seeing.
Therefore you could argue is the
real thing because it is the
Earth.
They saw what the weather's
doing on the Earth, whereas in
the CFD it's, it is a, a just a
numerical simulation.
And, and so that's the bit that
I still think is a bit of the
limitation, but we are so sparse
when it comes to data.
This is a bit of a segment into
a next question to you, which
has long been the argument of
the pins people, which is are we
ever going to have a vast
quantity of data to train sort
of data-driven models?
Is is that a reasonable
assumption or is it better to
say, well, actually we have
pretty well defined equations
and rules and models and is it
not just about using ML to solve
them faster?
Like do we need, if we have such
a a sparsity of data, do we not
need to include physics into the
models?
Where do you sort of lie on that
conundrum of just generating
more data and let the models of
the data or do we need to
incorporate more physics into
these models?
I'm very pragmatic in this.
I mean this, This was the same
in weather modelling.
Everyone was talking about
physics informed, not physics
informed.
But people only talk for, for,
for that amount of time until
they realise how heavy the data
loading is and how hard of a
machine learning problem that
is.
Because you don't want to talk
about the physics in form neural
network if you have to, to check
it between loading gigabytes of
data for one data point on the
GPO and what to do.
And in order to get this correct
and in order to get the decent
learning signal and so on and so
forth.
And I, I see it the same for
this engineering simulations.
We first have to be able to
really run simulations.
It's scale.
And I'm not talking about 10,000
cells.
I'm not talking about shape net,
I'm not talking about even
driving at the drive ML.
I'm talking about airplane
simulation and I'm talking about
transient simulation and that.
And we are still far away from
doing that both from how we
generate, how we store, how we
train data.
And I think only if we, if we
are able to really have a
workflow there and know what it
takes and know where it breaks
and, and, and where all these
problems are, we can then start
thinking about which type of
physics to include and and which
not because, I mean, we, we also
showed that in our paper, it's
very easy to build a diversions
free model for, for vorticity,
because you can bake in the, the
diversions free constraint,
their construction a hard
constraint.
We try the pin loss for the, for
the mass conservation, which is
much harder to just take the
great performance.
It in principle works.
And you would need some tricks
and I would say getting this to
work is not the amount of time
which needs to do all the
scaling.
But I would say that first the
problems we have to solve first
are the really how we interact
with numerics, how we scale to
these problems and then how we
actually get industry ready.
Well, you, you mentioned the
beginning, the sort of T to T +
1 analogy when it came to
weather.
And clearly the bit that we
missed out maybe in our
introduction is that the
engineering, we're not doing
that right.
You're going from yeah, straight
to a time average or something
at least, at least in, at least
in, well, in in the sort of way
that most of these data sets for
cars and planes have been to
date.
Given.
How would you change the
learning problem or the ML
architecture if now you had a a
full time history and would that
help hindrance not make a
difference?
I mean same argument as as we
have in in the spatial.
If you if you look at the the
neural network which has a few
megabytes of weights and which
compresses, I don't know the,
the GB CFD simulation or 10 or
20, I don't know how many GB
actually CFD simulation, you can
also play the same game over
time, right?
So neural network is just a
very, very good way of of
storing this, this information.
And if you somehow manage to to
store the temporal part in, in
some sort of modelling, which
allows you to give you the the
temporal answer to a certain
problem, this would be
tremendously huge gain.
Because suddenly you can really
simulate stuff in, in, in, in
real time, but also have the the
ability to observe what's going
on and, and, and to really
understand the temporal
dynamics.
Whereas the training is just
somehow pumping this simulation
into the neural network weights,
ideally without storing them.
But that's that's very, very
hard.
And then probably the next to,
next to next to step.
But yeah, I think first step is
to get to get the decent neural
network architectures for
temporal modelling, which we are
actually working on to be
honest.
OK.
And, and would you have the
sense to be something similar
where you know, you may want to
have a million time steps, but
that you'd expect that there
would be some way of, I don't
know, is there, is there a sort
of equivalency in terms of AD
inference?
Ideally you wouldn't need to go
1,000,000 steps, right?
Do you have a sense of how much
this is more question for people
who are generating data, You
know, do I need to generate a
million times steps of data so
that you can learn the million?
And do you expect that then you
would be able to predict to the
millionth but skip out every
hundred?
Because you, you don't need to,
you know, to do that?
Do you think you could learn the
temporal problem without every
single time step from the
traditional PDE?
Do you know what I'm trying to
get a sense of?
Like the how the temporal
challenge would link to the
spatial challenge?
I think it's it's very much
relatable.
So in in space we see this
phenomenon that you don't need
all the points to to to capture
the physics and then depend.
Then you have a huge advantage
in learning because you can
always sub sample different sets
of these points which give you a
huge data augmentation.
And you have the same in a
temporal domain.
You don't need each time step in
order to to present the full
physics to the neural network.
But obviously the the fine
grain, the more the more fine
graining you have in your in
your solution, the better you
can do the data augmentation in
the temporal dimension.
But obviously machine learning
models can do much, much bigger
time steps than numerical
models.
And yeah, this is something
which which is a true advantage.
They just don't work the same
and they don't have stability
issues but also no stability
guarantees well.
I was going to say, isn't that
one of the problems, the roll
out problem that, you know, I
guess if you do inference
inference, inference imprints,
you know, isn't, isn't these
sort of instabilities going to
build up or like, you know, how
do you constrain it?
Is this where some of the
physics needs to be added?
Do you think to sort of if you
need to do 100,000 iterations,
how much are you going to
guarantee that just a small
difference in that first is not
going to, you know, bifurcate
into different solutions?
Yeah, I mean, there, there is 2
to answer.
So that one is obviously you.
Luckily people do video
generation nowadays.
So we get a lot and lot of
tricks of video generation,
which actually really, really
start to make this thing stable.
And one of these, these
definitely modeling paradigms is
this generative model that you
model the distribution over time
and that you kind of make sure
the distribution always stays
the same.
And, and this boils down to a
bit of, of physics
understanding, right?
If you, if you make sure the
distribution is the same, if you
make sure that that future and
past they considered that there
is a tension across the right
axis and so on and so forth, we
get stability.
It's always depends on how you
define physics.
For me, it's the information the
model needs and the way you,
you, you, you interact with
future and past and so on.
I truly think that this
generative modelling is there's
the breakthrough in this, this
rollout stabilities.
I remember when I ran first into
this rollout problems, it was I
think 4 years ago and, and, and
basically I, I did this paper
together with Daniel Worrell and
I texted him and saying, hey, I
don't know, we have to do
something.
Our rollouts always exploding.
And then I have no idea.
And, and he said, well, yeah,
there has to be some, some
tricks in literature and then
something smart and, and, and
definitely people have thought
about it.
And I was like, yeah, I cannot
find anything.
There is like, why is nobody
having this problem?
And it's basically just a very
different problem we have in in
in this engineering task that
the the input itself each time
step is so huge from information
content that every
autoaggressive model, every
every autoaggressive trick you
you had before is just not
working because they work with
much smaller input vectors.
But but now that computer vision
is going to videos and that
people are aware of this problem
and that frequency spectrum need
to be conserved and so on and so
forth.
This guess really a lot of lot
of progress.
And I would say that that the
having the frequency spectrum
stable is is is what made many
of these things stable.
So it sounds like in a way there
is still a lot of potential to
learn from the other advances.
Yeah, in ML, you know, the fact
there's always an analogy
problem I guess is what you're
saying.
There's the stuff you can learn
in terms of video generation,
text generation, weather,
climate week.
You can borrow ideas from other
fields, but it suggests that you
therefore need to have people
with a a broader ML background.
You know, if you just have a
fluids background, you may
struggle to solve this problem
because you need to know what or
you need to have an
understanding and an interest in
looking at what's video
generation doing or what's this
doing.
Would that be fair to say?
This is why it's a
multidisciplinary problem.
Almost all you need a team that
is multidisciplinary.
I mean that that's happening in
biotech and in other areas as
well, right?
We are just very in agnostic to
that and language and vision
because you don't need a
linguist to build the LLM and
you don't need basically, I
don't know even what the
computer vision like.
What's that analogy there?
But for, for, for, for all this
alpha fold and so on so forth.
The surely had domain experts on
the team and surely this is
what, what's the exciting part
about engineering you, you have
problems which are so hard to
correct that you need the top
notch machine learning people
that the top notch domain
people, they need to speak the
same language.
And even if you can borrow a lot
of concepts, they need to be
heavily adjusted.
Because the problem with this
large mesh is with what's the
input, what's the output?
There's this huge ratio
difference and, and, and, and
turbulence and whatnot.
This is just a, a totally
different piece to, to crack.
So that's what's the exciting
part here.
I, I wanted to maybe pivot it a
little bit to the process you
went in creating a start up.
I, I think a lot of people would
be interested to know and I'm
sure other people, you know, are
in a pub or, you know, alcohol
doesn't need to be involved, of
course, but you know, there's
somewhere and they've got ideas
and, but not many people
actually go out secure funding
and, you know, create a start
up.
So obviously not giving away any
sensitive details, but what was
that experience like for you?
Like how did it begin?
How did you deal with venture
capital companies, how to like?
Yeah, I'd be interested if you
could share some of your
experience in founding a start
up, some of the lessons learnt
maybe.
Yeah, so I mean, I, I was really
lucky.
So, so first of all, a lot of
knowledge comes up from my
university.
I, I have to know, I have to say
that the people like Benedict
Alkin and and Tobiascon Lachner
who are really, really pushing
the efforts, they have been with
me from, from day one actually.
Also people like Stefan Berka
here in Linz University is a
well known simulation expert who
who knows all these tricks.
When I met him the first day,
basically after returning to
Austria, we were 5 minutes and
we were both like super excited
that, that we do things in this
area.
And yeah, we, there was a lot of
momentum there.
We were at a different company
and XCI where at some point it
was clear that the simulation
team, which was was really
working well, should branch off.
I was also lucky to to have met
people like Dennis Houston mix
Mickelson's who who did this
before graded startups, very
successful startups and actually
knew what to do.
They were the first to listen to
me when I told them, hey, this
engineering like scaling these
things up.
What we do to this billion of
mesh problems is actually what
what industry needs.
But just give us some time.
We will figure that out.
And so I think it was all very
natural.
It was not planned, but it's
obviously a huge excitement if
you can, if you can do what
you're really burning for in,
in, in also in a, in a
commercial set up where you you
really can make an impact with
what you're doing.
So yeah, I would say in that
sense I was very lucky.
And I would also say that
especially in this area, we, we
see a lot of momentum generated
and we're not the last start up
and there is hopefully coming
more it, it, it there is a
momentum especially in Europe
now in in this area.
And yeah, just very exciting.
I would do it exactly the same
way again.
And so how do you think you
could have done this any other
way?
Do you think you could have come
up with what you're coming up at
a company or at the university
or is it is this is the start up
really the only way of I asked
this question because I asked
the same thing to Max Welling
and he was sort of saying, well,
yeah, start-ups is the only
place where this can happen.
The university's either too
small and doesn't have enough
funding or companies too big and
too slow.
And the start up is this sort
of, but it feels like in Europe,
but often a bit risk averse.
We almost feel like start-ups is
for somebody else.
But I'd be interested to know
your thoughts on.
That I'm not so sure if what
we're pulling off.
We just need the, the, the best
people and, and, and, and some
compute.
One thing which is really,
really, really, really hard is
the problems.
So it's actually we are choosing
our customer mostly by the, the,
the, the scale and size of the
problems they have because
they're really interesting
problems come from industry and
the more challenging and those
problems are, the better they
are for us and, and for
developing us.
So obviously we now have have a
customer which have huge
temporal problems where you
have, we have different
modalities interacting and this
can bootstrap our temporal
modelling capabilities and and
and and and and and and, and,
and this is something which you
wouldn't get in the industry I
at university.
So I would say it's a mixture.
I would say for me, it's, it's,
it really helps to get hands on
to the, to the real problems
and, and on, on the other side,
it's, it's just helps me to get
into touch what industry really
needs and, and not sit in my
ivory tower.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't stand
doing things where I know people
wouldn't use them.
So this is a good, yeah, good
mix.
But I also have to say there is
luckily some people like Neil
Ashton who generate publicly
available data sets that that
people can really start looking
at that We just have to give the
community the urgency that that
they really look at the hard
data sets and not a shape, no
car.
Yeah, it, it seems like the
there is definitely a movement
in the industry towards this
machine learning problems.
You know, every time I go to a
conference, there's more and
more people doing it, but it
still feels like we haven't
reached that inflection point.
It still feels like you're
either a start up or you're, I
don't know.
It still feels like we're not
fully at that yeah, inflection
point in terms of mass adoption
of this.
I feel like we're getting
closer.
I'm sure you feel the same.
You know, lots of industries
interested, but maybe it is the
data that's the issue.
Maybe it's the Era 5 was such a
large open data set that data
wasn't the issue and therefore
people just got into the
modelling.
Whereas I feel like now there's
been quite a lot of advances in
let's say Rd. car external
aerodynamics.
But Rd. car external
aerodynamics, I don't know
percentage wise, but it's it's a
small percentage of the entire
CFD domain.
And yeah, yeah, it feels like we
still need to convince maybe the
whole CFD community to do more,
to really advance it and make
this a more systematic, I guess.
Would that be true to say that
you can only work on the
problems that you updated for?
I mean, it sounds like an
obvious statement to make, but I
assume if you had 10 times more
data, you could potentially go
and hire more people and work on
more problems.
But you're not going to go and
hire more people and work on
other problems if there isn't
the data or the willingness to
do this.
And, and most people also don't
know what to, to optimise for,
right.
So, so I think the, the, the
industry or the, the, the real
problems need to need to set
the, the, the, the, the, the
stage they need to set the, the
machine learning problem.
Then we can start to think of
how to solve it.
Yeah, I, I, but there is a
momentum.
People are still reluctant
because getting a nervous paper
easier on a smaller data set
than on a larger data set.
But but I think there is quite
some movement and and and and
things are are really changing.
And I also from for me, it's,
it's kind of our philosophy that
to be a bit open source to show
our models to show what we're
doing to publish, because I
think this is this is the way to
go forward.
Closed, closed doors policy is
is is not, not what what what
gets progress.
I mean, we we see that the whole
progress in LLM due to open
source and then and so on and so
forth.
And I think this is also what
will, not what should, but what
will happen in in this space.
Yeah, I must say that I do
commend that you're releasing
the data and the models.
Open source is is a novelty.
And I think, yeah, it's good to
see because I like particularly
your paper now.
I mean, I think that has hurt a
little bit of trust in the CFD
world so far.
Instead, as you know, the
tradition and I'm don't sure
where the tradition came from.
If you develop a turbans model
or you develop a numerical
method, whatever it is, it's
almost always published.
It's very rare actually for a
model to make itself into a
large commercial, even, you
know, ISVCFD code and not to
have a corresponding
publication.
It's sort of seen as like a
thing that you don't make money
on the method, you make money on
the code.
That's sort of been the like
thing like open foam or star CCM
or anti fluid to others,
typically the models themselves.
You sort of know it's more the
the the little tricks that you
might do and but then more the
support and the code and all
that.
Whereas it felt like so far in
the ML4 CAE world, with the
exception of a a couple of
individuals or or companies,
most of the start-ups have not
published or made a thing of
saying, here's our exact method,
but we've implemented it in such
a way that, do you know what I
mean?
And I feel like that's hurt a
little bit of trust because it's
hard for someone to believe
results if they don't see a
publication about it.
So yeah, I don't know if I'm
alone on this, but I think your
strategy of publishing more, I
think actually helps at least
CFD people to feel a little bit
more like comfortable.
Which I, I, I think it's the,
it's the only way around.
And I if I make a bold
statement, if in the machine
learning world where things are
moving so fast you're afraid
that others are are copying your
stuff and overtaking you, you
should probably reconsider your
your capabilities as a company.
Yeah.
And the only thing I would say
though, which is why I've asked
you sometimes to up level the
explanations, is I feel maybe
even the biggest barrier is just
an understanding barrier that,
you know, if you're ACFD person,
you're probably going to read an
ML paper and be like, I don't
really understand this.
That's almost the challenge.
You know, it's like an education
thing is that the people making
decisions or higher up may not
even understand because it's
such a different field that that
is the challenge.
So anything that you can do to
make like, yeah, simpler
versions of papers or like
summaries of papers or, or
education, which I guess comes
back to why having a dual
affiliation between a university
and a start up is probably a
good thing.
Because I feel that you need to
be teaching and producing like
open source teaching material to
educate people as much as also
producing commercial solutions.
I don't know if you've noticed
that when you speak to customers
that sometimes they're just
knowledge of ML is part of the
blocker.
Yeah, but it's also the other
way around, right?
There's hardly any people who
have the knowledge of the real
domain expertise and knowledge
of ML because only if you have
the knowledge of domain
expertise and you know what ML
can do, you really find the
problems where ML can really
have an impact, right?
And, and and this goes in both
ways.
So education both ways is super
important and it's very, very
hard.
I mean, I, I see that myself all
the time that I can get lost in
details and, and, and think
things are obvious.
And on the other hand, when I
talk to real domain experts I
get get really lost and have to
ask questions and yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, maybe This is why it still
will take a few years to reach a
greater maturity because both
sides need to upskill themselves
and, and, and sort of learn.
So great.
Well, really appreciate you
chatting.
I mean, what I'm going to do is
put some links in at least on
the YouTube to, to a couple of
the papers and the models that
you that we've referred to,
because I think people should
really spend a bit of time
looking at the papers.
I have a feeling that, you know,
we might need to chat again.
I think this field is moving so
quickly that everything that we,
it'll be interesting to see if
we listen to this conversation,
a year's time, are we going to
be completely wrong or in two
years time?
I very much hope so.
But what we won't be wrong is
that some things are moving fast
and that we will have fast
progress in two years.
So we will be, oh, we didn't
expect that to happen, so.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's going to happen.
That's a good thing though.
Maybe that maybe that's OK.
But yeah, for now, then, until
we speak again, thank you very
much and yeah, hope people that
enjoy looking at your paper and
your work.
Thank you very much, Neil for
having me.